while we're still waiting on official
confirmation of the rumor that Charlie
Cox is Matt Murdock aka daredevil will
appear in the upcoming third spider-man
movie as Peter Parker's lawyer
it seems the fate of one of Cox's
co-stars on Netflix as the defenders
might be starting to take shape
according to we got this covered Marvel
brass may be looking to slot the one and
only Luke Cage into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the near future with the
hero of Harlem reportedly set to feature
as a prominent supporting player moving
forward the rumor is hardly
substantiated as the outlet cites an
unnamed Marvel insider as a source the
same elite Cox is possible MCU returned
in spider-man 3
it appears that Marvel Entertainment
chief creative officer Kevin Feige isn't
looking to simply forget all of the
Netflix small screen MCU ventures he's
reportedly looking to integrate not only
daredevil and Luke agents of the MCU but
also Jessica Jones and The Punisher with
Krysten Ritter and Jon Bernthal both
possibly reprising their roles most
surprisingly the rumor claims that
Marvel isn't interested in bringing
actor Mike Colter buckas Cage the studio
is reportedly looking to recast the role
her fate apparently also shared by Iron
Fist Finn Jones if these rumors turn out
to be true let's hope that Marvel finds
an actor who can balance physicality and
emotion as well as Colter did over his
time in the Netflix world of the MCU yo
I'm doing the best I can okay
Marvel is bringing some of its big
screen heroes at a small screen via
Disney Plus so it's not unreasonable to
believe that perhaps the studio wants to
blend the heroes of those Netflix series
into the ever-expanding cinematic
universe according to Variety certain
legalities between Marvel and Netflix
may prevent any of the characters who
appeared on those streaming series from
joining in the MCU until at least two
years after their respective series
ended daredevil ed is final run of
episodes in October 2018 so it will be
at least another year before we see the
man without fear in the MCU
for the Punisher and Jessica Jones the
wait would be a little longer as final
episodes of their series aired in
January and June of 2019 respectively as
for a possible timeline on a Luke Cage
return he was last seen getting cozy and
Harlan's paradise in June 2018 so it's
possible he could be punching his way
back into the MCU sooner than any of the
other defenders on a plane or
hibernating
I was innocent before and I'm innocent
now about work to do part of the reason
these particular characters made their
debuts and small-screen ventures is
because Marvel probably had the marked
as worthy heroes that likely wouldn't
have drawn huge audiences the theaters
in a standalone movie Daredevils only
solo movie venture is not well-regarded
let's say Luke Cage in particular seemed
to benefit from the episodic approach as
well as from teaming up with other
supers and Netflix's Marvel Canon
memorably pairing with both Jessica
Jones and iron fist prior to and after
the defenders run cage has been one of
Marvel Comics most team-up friendly
heroes over the years so if Feige and
the current Marvel crew are eyeing him
as a major supporting character in
whatever MCU fund they might be planning
there's a chance of a hero of Harlem
could sign up alongside some more
established supers right out of the
gates cages status as an Avenger has
been well established in the comics and
if the MCU truly is looking to build his
next Avengers big screen run cage could
find himself in the mix when the next
crossover occurs we could also see
Marvel go the Heroes for Hire roots and
deposit cage in the company of his
defenders Powell's iron fist and Jessica
Jones it's also been rumored that Marvel
is looking to bring an alternate
supergroup into the MCU in the near
future
the Thunderbolts and yes Luke Cage can
frequently be seen fighting alongside
that crew too so cages possible return
to the MCU could take on many different
looks could it happen
of course might it be an alt announced
fast sure Marvel rumors are a dime a
dozen but there's potentially a lot to
look forward to if he does find his way
back check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the pal so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]